die treppen rauf geschlafen wie noch nie
zum soll für die bahner auf zu gar nicht
schlecht wie sie unsere zu groß zwischen
hamburg gibt er der frau liebst du gehst
kann ich mich da zu setzen
juni mi dazu besitzen nur jetzt auch
schon seit 21 jahren in dem dorf im
bügel du kannst bairisch reden oder
durst dazu - branche geworden und fräsen
warum grund sie besitzen zu gestorben
[Gelächter]
leiden sie unter zu wenig bauch hätten
sie gerne eine richtig schöne wampe
dann schauen sie mal wo noch da im
schaufenster gleich nebenan
[Musik]
jung legt obama richtig schlecht für
preis ja auch nur mit einer rufe hier
hast du keine folge eine erhältlich in
den größen xs xxl